- So you also have a travel
show, which I think is awesome.
So you search for happiness.
So you kind of pull from
your uncle a little bit.
- Yeah.
- Do you think beauty is a part of that?
- You know, it's interesting
that we're talking about this
'cause I hadn't really thought about that.
I'm about to leave.
Next week I go around the world
for a show called The Geography of Bliss.
Looking for happiness around the world
and what makes people happy.
Why are some cultures so much
better at creating happiness
in their population than others?
And, you know, what secrets can we find
and kind of bring back home.
- [Kelly] Yeah
- So we're going to Bulgaria
and Iceland and Ghana
and Africa and Japan and Thailand.
- Who are you doing this with?
- Peacock, Universal.
- Yeah. Are you traveling
with anyone though?
Anybody in your family going, or?
- It's just me, searching for happiness.
- [Kelly] That's awesome.
- But I think that this beauty idea
is something that I should investigate.
- Yeah. I love the idea of
searching for happiness.
They always do that with the, you know,
what tribes live the longest
or what areas of the world-
- [Rainn] Yeah.
they're blue.
They're called blue something or blue?
I can't remember what they're called.
- Blue Zones or something like that.
- Blue Zones. Blue Zones.
Yeah. That's interesting though.
I wonder, at the end of like, your journey
if it'll be like, if simple is better.
'Cause I feel like we complicate life
with all the things, right?
So I wonder if people that you
find are living more simpler-
- Simpler lives
- Are happier.
- Yeah. I'm not sure what we'll find.
I mean, there's-
- [Kelly] Yeah. Iceland's beautiful.
- Yes, I've been before. It's incredible.
It's one of my favorite places.
- It's got so many things going on there.
- Yeah.
- Like the black thing and the waterfall.
There's so many things, it's so pretty.
- [Rainn] Yeah. That's one of my,
I've been already four times to Iceland
- [Kelly] Oh wow.
- And that's one of the, it's
one of the happiest places
on earth and it's
incredible because you just
like you said, you'll be
sitting on a black sand beach.
There's a glacier on
one side of you there's,
you know, hot springs over here.
There's like a thousand
foot waterfall behind you.
- Yeah.
- And then you've seen 10 of
those and you're like, ho hum.
You know? Oh geeze.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Yeah. Another thousand foot waterfall.
- I think that affects us too though.
Happiness. That's why I
like to get outta the city-
- [Rainn] Yeah.
- and go into nature.
I think nature that's
obviously why you have
a place in Oregon, like
the cabin just to get out.
- Yeah. It's good to get out the city.
- It feels good.
- Yeah, absolutely, absolutely.
All right. We need another break.
Stream Rainn's movie,
Jerry and Marge Go Large
on Paramount+ and look for him soon,
traveling the world in Rainn Wilson
and The Geography of Bliss on Peacock,
which I will not be missing.
I'm excited about that.